good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy
friday friday gotta get down on friday
it's actually not friday it's friday
because the streis brothers are here if
you're watching on youtube our wide
camera angle is a little different today
so you can get a view of the gorgeous
boys bryce strice thrice bruno and theo
are all here the streis brothers have
come to town you guys it is a lot of
people worry about day a lot of people
talk about the impact the wright
brothers had on history and i think that
the way we speak about the streis
brothers moving forward will be of equal
caliber if not more strice brothers
greater than wright brothers you heard
it here first they're munching on their
bones they're being good boys for now
and we are just
taking in every moment of being working
parents working parents we've been
talking about them so much on the show i
guess because of the pillows that like
we just had this gaping hole in our
hearts
and bruno hasn't been to the show in
like actually a year and he was ready he
said mom i'm ready and i said bru get
your [ __ ] ass up and work it seems
like nobody wants to work these days no
it's so true and it's like the official
mascots of our business
they were due for a little overtime they
were due
theo used to come here every single day
i know and you could tell this morning i
actually went to your apartment first we
had like a little play date we're so
cute and sweet you could tell like when
he realized that he was going to work he
had this spring in his step his he
really does have this way about him
that's so i'm like feeling distracted
i'm i don't know how funny it can be
today because i'm just looking into the
eyes of my son i'm so proud of him i say
that's my baby and i'm proud
yeah they're being so cute they also
match with their blue harnesses
unintentional just like how we match
every day yeah and if you're listening
as a podcast head over to the youtube
and don't forget to [ __ ]
subscribe don't forget her claudia's
gonna come for you i will come for your
neck
um and then you can also like subscribe
to premium content and see two gorgeous
wonderful human beings so
i couldn't think of a reason why you
shouldn't so i said what i said
she said what she said um aside from
streis how was your evening i know you
had a traumatic evening a traumatic
evening yeah no the trauma is still
fresh for me in case you don't watch my
instagram stories
something so crazy happened to me
i'm still processing i know honestly
i decided last night to cook because
there's a salad that i always order that
i love and i'm like you know what i
think i can make it
make it healthier and more
cost-effective
and so i was cutting up a red cabbage
and as i was like scooping up my cabbage
i saw like a little like what seemed to
be like a little wet shriveled piece of
cabbage so i went to touch and i'm like
that's a [ __ ] frog
frog frog frog on my cutting board frog
in my house frogging my cabbage i
screamed and you're wearing a band-aid
on the finger so this actually is the
finger that touched the frog and i
literally couldn't even look at this
finger like i literally wouldn't let it
touch anything even after i washed it a
million times and then later in the
evening i was opening a package and the
scissor cut my finger that finger's
cursed and it was it's a freudian cut
because like i wanted to damage this
finger like i wanted
to it was your subconscious i wanted to
have to cover it up so yes this is the
finger now it's it's not going to
contaminate anything that's because i
did cut myself opening a package with
this gorgeous sweater in it how are you
feeling post frog i'm feeling weird
honestly
like there was a [ __ ] frog in my
house frogs are not something maybe if i
lived in florida like okay frogs are
they were good but in new york
where does a frog come from no i have no
idea where you would even find a frog i
mean i saw a rat on the street last
night like that's my life i would be i
mean i would rather see a frog in my
house than a rat uh-huh but i would be
less confused but the frog really did
come from the cabbage patch because the
cabbage was a packaged cabbage so it was
in plastic and then it was in the
grocery store vegetable bag you know
when you like grab a plastic bag so i
believe it came from the patch and it
was the same color as the cabbage it was
a red cabbage um
the the outer layers of the cabbage
which are very dark
so it's probably been living there for a
while
alive um
a lot of people were curious and i do
have a photo of it and i know i said i
would post it but i just like don't want
a frog on my instagram story i can't
explain it no i'll post it for you and
like i always you know go through my
instagram story i don't want to keep
seeing this frog i know and people ask
me for a picture so like i send it to
them got it and i don't even look at it
you know so i just want to say like as
human beings especially those who live
in new york like a part of our
daily life is going to be every now and
then running into some sort of vermin in
new york it's mostly roaches and mice
which are like the two worst ones um so
i just feel like you
we're everyone every couple of years is
due for some sort of vermin sighting and
you got yours out of the way and it was
a frog and it was a small frog and like
i'm not you know
belittling your trauma but just it could
have been so much worse you know a
hundred percent but like that cabbage
was in my fridge for two days like my
son's milk is in there like it's just
yeah no that's tough for sure it's
harrowing that's tough and you know that
for dogs i don't know if it applies to
frogs but like toads are deadly for dogs
if they lick a toad you're right there's
poisonous and like so what if the frog
went on the floor and bruno was like hey
little friend right and bruno's fast
like he would snatch that frog up in two
seconds and
then bruno paid the price by the fatal
price i forgot about that like there's
just so many things that
that could have happened that's this
frog was living in my fridge for two
days like that's just
alongside my breast milk no it's it's a
lot it's definitely a lot and i
apologize that you had to go through
that but as our queen kelly clarkson
once said what doesn't kill you makes
you stronger but it nearly killed me it
nearly did and we killed bryce and you
will come back from this bigger and
better than ever yeah so that was my
evening i don't know what else happened
and also like the adrenaline rush of
like screaming of the house like in
chaos because of the frog like even in
my video like you can hear harry
screaming like because he heard mom
screaming the whole balance of the home
was was off then like 30 minutes later
like
everything came down and i was exhausted
like i was already tired but to like
have such an adrenaline rush
oh my god it wiped me out no it'll
that'll do it and that'll do it i'm so
deeply sorry for what you went through
thank you that means a lot it's horrible
and really everyone's just like
realizing that it's a crazy thing to see
a frog no one was like oh that's fine
yeah no it's not like a little like
fruit fly right it's not a it's a
[ __ ] frog in new york city you
probably traveled that what do you think
that cabbage was grown like california
yeah but uh some people were messaging
me like at least you know it's fresh
produce because one frog is still alive
after subsisting just on cabbage that's
true and there's no pesticides that
would have killed the frog so you
obviously didn't eat any of the cabbage
right
no got it okay
i was chopping it
and then of course it made me look at my
whole kitchen so what did you end up
eating for dinner i had already cooked
salmon that was really sitting there and
it looked beautiful so i had that and i
had some minute rice love minute rice
and i had vegetables uh that were
formerly frozen i would take a bullet
for minute rice honestly it's really
good and there's like the whole brown
rice has no sodium the brown rice is so
good yeah so that's what i had which was
good i wanted to make this like bowl
that i usually get that's brown rice
chunks of salmon red cabbage red onion
carrots i was gonna and
never again it didn't happen just keep
ordering it okay
for sure even though like what if they
found a frog in the cabbage i would
never know
what you don't know is for your own
health ignorance is bliss we have an
amazing show for you guys today it is
friday so we're going to deliver the
fast five we are going to recap the
kardashians episode from this week um
and just moving forward i saw i got a
lot of messages like can't believe you
guys didn't recap kardashians i don't
know how you expect us to recap
kardashians on thursdays when it
literally comes out on thursday the
morning to 9 00 pm oh but you're kidding
yeah but you know what i can't reca i
can't watch two shows in a night
so that
is why i like this better oh good for
them for moving it so why don't they
just say it comes out on wednesdays like
i don't know
okay good i didn't know that that's
great that is great but still i think we
should plan to recap kardashians on
fridays because i can't watch beverly
hills and kardashians on thursdays
okay so that'll be in the tv recap but
just quick tv you know what i watched
last night um
the hall you know netflix uh created
like a comedy hall of fame and they had
their first induction and they had this
whole event it was part of the netflix
comedy festival um and it was honoring
and well inducting
queen joan which is why i was watching
george carlin richard pryor and robin
williams and they had a comedian for
each
comedian who had passed away to like
honor and chelsea handler was the one
who
did joan and this is going to be an
extremely hot take because it was like
good but it should have been better and
i just
don't think chelsea was the woman for
the job
who do you think was me
um i don't know but like
there was no like enthusiasm behind her
voice and she's just not that type of
per like talker so i i don't know it's
just
i don't know i was like a little
disappointed so you wouldn't recommend
no but it did then make me want to watch
um
jones most recent special
which is so it's just crazy like how
different the times are now um
because literally like there's stuff on
there that would like literally ruin
someone's life right now like you would
literally like
no job no home no car what special is it
um i don't know what it's called but
it's the only one on netflix and it's
her in chicago and the whole show is
basically like i'm going to get to my
show but i just want to like kick out a
few people like a few groups first
so it's like old people have to go and
literally i was cackling she was like
the gays the gays of course you can stay
gay men in the front and lesbians in the
back because gay men laugh at everything
and lesbians laugh at nothing they're
just like that's funny
that's me literally and i'm saying i'm
like i literally do that i don't laugh
i'm like that's funny no i'm the worst
at a comedy show because when i think
something is hysterical my laughter is
silent and then i just punch everybody
near me but just like hearing her talk
about like different races like it's so
out there um and i feel like when it
came out it was like crazy but it's not
like this is like career ending stuff
you know i have to watch it it was just
wild um there's just not enough joan
river rivers footage out there i mean
i've said it once i'll say it again like
if you haven't watched your documentary
like you're literally missing out
on a piece of work that will change your
life and it's called a piece of work
yeah
i think a lot of people have watched it
and we talked about all the time we
literally talked about it yesterday no i
know it's i feel like my mission on
earth is to get as many people to see
that documentary as possible i feel like
it's important and there's a lot of good
valuable life lessons in there for sure
you're doing a good job yeah oh man that
just reminds me i had like two
two okay four cocktails last night
and ben texted me
did he watch the episode did he or what
he said about him has he landed us an
invite to the buckingham palace yet no
but you know what he lended me an invite
for this is [ __ ] ben
a tour of joan rivers penthouse what
yeah i have forgot to message can i come
yeah can strike brothers come no
they'll pee all over it i want to see
joan's apartment
that is so crazy that i missed that but
i was like busy i went out last night i
saw the snatcher which was really just
did you just run into the snatcher or
you synced up i synced up with a snatch
we were you know we were doing different
things but then we synced up at the end
our cycles synced up
and um
i went to fleming restaurant and i just
have to give a shout out because they
have a whole menu of kosher meat items
and it's not a kosher restaurant it's
just like kosher meat so if you're like
super kosher it's like not kosher enough
for you but like for me it was fine yeah
um and i just feel like people didn't
know that so i didn't it was i have to
go back like i had steak i never get to
eat steak yum how was the snatcher this
snatcher was snatching
anything new with her that we should
know about she was wearing a leather
jacket that honestly i didn't like at
all and i didn't want to be like
negative like i hate your jacket but i
didn't meant to tell her this morning to
burn the jacket you need to tell someone
not while they're wearing it making them
ruining their night like tell them the
next day like i just wouldn't wear that
jacket again no it was so like
motorcycle to the point of like do you
have a picture of her from no i don't
i might have this it was like i i meant
to i thought about it this morning all
while i was getting ready i'm like i
must tell snatcher to burn that jacket
but maybe she really likes it like what
the [ __ ] do i know you know so true like
what does my opinion mean what were you
wearing literally no actually doing a
sickening norma kamali jumpsuit so look
at you yep i saw a picture of you you
looked good oh thanks thanks so much so
it's a lovely thursday night kickoff to
the weekend and we're almost there you
guys acknowledge the space that you're
in it is friday morning that is so much
life ahead of you it's supposed to rain
tonight which is just fabulous weekend
weather oh my god
beautiful so we listen to alarm free
living everyone just close your eyes
acknowledge be grateful for the days
ahead of alarm free living
i don't need an alarm my alarm is my son
it's so true my rose is my husband and
my alarm
um
okay so now you feel ready yeah okay so
without further a do do where you you're
right here being so cute with your
stripes brother it is time for the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
brothers and
peloton
hand pellets
no by the way something you don't know
because you're not a singer um it's
really important to like enunciate so
when i say and i'm like han and i'm
breathy like like ariana grande again
something else you wouldn't understand
so um come at me again about my singing
i won't but i just need to say i read
some podcast reviews and there was one
that was like what are you doing i don't
know i don't know what happened there
was one that was just like like like
everyone hates the singing but we don't
care but then everyone was like well you
know what like claudia can sing and like
jackie like really thinks that she has a
good voice i just want you guys to know
like i don't think that i have that's
not true i know that i do
i know that you do too no like you guys
i know my voice is trash that's like the
joke no okay it's a comedy podcast and
you i know my voice is trash i just want
you guys to know like just stop you got
it twisted
no they were extraordinary why what else
oh they say about me what did they say
about you no they should use them
we could do another patreon like there's
enough in there that it's like so it's
literally like 4chan it's so unhinged
it's so unhinged and the craziest is
when like people love the show and
they're like but i hate the singing
whatever and they give you like a
two-star but they love the show right
but like one thing bothers you about it
and so
what's new what's the latest oh
yikes someone wrote one star yikes you
hate to see that worse it's not the vibe
seems like the vibe has shifted after
their maternity leave yeah this was this
was something i saw once or twice that
like people don't like my energy oh and
we're harmful to the ed community i
can't everyone like please
uh they don't like my post-maternity
energy
and i just have to say like i love it
this is disgusting
this is [ __ ] disgusting i wish you
didn't bring this up ready one star
claudia's voice slash demeanor changes
when she speaks to anyone younger than
her
holding so tightly to being 21 living
vicariously through margot
then she interviews adults that don't
keep up with the kardashians and she has
nothing to contribute get out of here
with that ageist garbage seriously [ __ ]
you
i'm back to peloton oh my god that
ruined my whole day i'm so sorry i'll
just face it please never bring up
podcaster museum like why did i think
that was gonna be fun i don't know you
did it i just wanted to say like i know
i can sing
great
on opposite
uh
peloton tell them about it because i
freaking love peloton peloton has
thousands of live and on-demand classes
so you can always keep it fresh from
cycling and strength training to yoga
and running and you can experiment with
new types of movement judgment free at a
level at a pace that feels good to you
so peloton obviously
everyone's obsessed jackie's obsessed
with her bike you don't even need the
bike to be peloton you they have amazing
live stream classes
the app has everything all different
kinds of classes treadmill workouts i
mean running you can run on a different
treadmill you can run in the streets you
can run somewhere bucolic and beautiful
they have everything they have yoga they
have free weights
every part of the body any type of class
you want to do it's working with pelton
obviously cycling as well and they have
the peloton bike and the peloton tread
you have the pelton bike obviously
and i'm waiting to get the peloton tried
on so fast oh you are going to yes i'm
going to because i love the peloton
tread workout so much and i'm like i
need to use what olivia motto is using
because i want to be just like her
peloton fits seamlessly into your life
if you're looking for a 10 minute upper
body stretch between calls or a 40
minute run before bed peloton works with
your schedule whether you have five
minutes or an hour plus you'll never
have an awkward encounter in a locker
room ever again right now is the perfect
time to try out peloton because the
peloton bike plus is now five hundred
dollars less it is their best price yet
and that includes free delivery and
setup
there are more game changing prices
available right now on the original
peloton bike and the peloton tread all
at one pelotom.com
visit onepeleton.com to learn more
today's episode is also brought to you
by betterhelp and if you want to follow
me on peloton my name is jackie o w and
i really am i'm really talented at
finding great classes so you can look at
all the classes that i've done and
they're probably flames jackie
today's episode is also brought to you
by betterhelp we associate burnout with
work but that's not the only cause a lot
of our roles in life can lead us to feel
burned out and better help online
therapy wants to remind you to
prioritize yourself talking with someone
can help you figure out what's causing
stress in your life of course work is
stressful but you might not realize
other things that are like weighing on
you whether that's your friendships
family stuff being a mom is so hard um
so it's so nice to have someone to talk
to about everything in your life and
better help is a really great resource
at helping you find a licensed therapist
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours the morning
toast listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
toast that's betterhelp.com
toast i love today's episode we're
looking out for your physical health and
your mental health that is what you can
come to expect at the morning toast
balance we don't support the ed
community and
that was a joke it was a joke
it was a joke we're in the comedy
section i can't i started maybe that's
what that person's referring to like i
started to give less [ __ ] recently
yeah and no i think that's like what
they're referring to i think for me too
like definitely my post-maternity energy
has changed because i have less patience
than i once did and i don't really like
beat around the bush because there's
just no time
and i think that's what that person is
picking up i'm like yes and i do like it
though yeah no but also like
if you have a platform and like you talk
about everything going on in the world
like yes some days people aren't going
to like what you say so if you make your
whole
goal with your podcast is to like avoid
any landmines and not offend a single
person slightly like it's the worst
podcast of all time silence
45 minutes of silence silence so you
know if you hear something that you
don't like on the toast that is totally
fine and normal because people are
different
right and you can keep listening
fine but if you can handle difference if
you can't handle difference that's true
find another show no and i think that's
a place where at like in our culture
where people can't handle people with
different opinions right and i don't
think that the solution is that we all
need to have the same opinion and i also
don't think the solution is labeling
people as not supporting the eg
community because my opinion was that i
didn't think what kim did was that crazy
like
that makes me
not supporting the eg like these great
these
grand statements we make it's just like
it's terrible no it's terrible but like
i know that the majority of people who
listen to the show don't feel that way
and are normal people and we love you
and support you and we'll stop talking
about everyone else
are you ready for our first story which
is some beautiful joyful news it's the
first story oh my god that's the only
thing that could
make these people more upset if you add
the final story song to every single
story it's the second story
i can't believe people don't like the
singing like it's shocking to me no but
it's like to me
it's so funny and like really like we
are a live musical podcast and we're
doing it on the fly the talent in this
room
astronomical astronomical and it's
wasted from these podcast reviewers you
know what you know we are i just i just
figured it out
we're not appreciated in our own time
like shakespeare wasn't appreciated in
his own time it was until years later
that people really discovered the true
talent of shakespeare yeah long after he
was gone you know when we will be
appreciated when we're dead
oh you hate to see it no but that does
you know make the afterlife a little bit
more exciting
yeah but like
i guess i guess so i want to say
something crazy you know what
it's friday here's the floor no i've
actually been thinking about this a lot
and i told ben at one time because like
you know life is so you know
crazy like anything can happen to you
and there are these freak accidents
where people young people healthy people
they die
and i just wanted to go on the record
and i told ben this but i want to have
it like in memoriam in real life if
anything like that ever happens to me
i just want you guys to know like i
won't be scared like i'm like not that i
want to die but like i'm very curious
about what happens next like i think
that there's more for us
so
while it's sad that my time here on
earth is obviously over and i will miss
my family greatly just know like i'm not
afraid of death i'm not looking forward
to it but i'm not afraid of it okay so
when we're like talking about you oh she
must have been so scared in those final
moments no i don't think that i will
honestly it depends what the final
moments are no of course i'm like being
held up at gunpoint in like a bank
robbery yeah no but if it's like if i'm
you know in a car crash god forbid you
know knock wood knock wood knock wood
knock whatever oh [ __ ] bruno thinks
there's someone at the door oh god oh my
god that scared the [ __ ] out of me i'm
sorry i'm so sorry i
was just trying to not get like
superstition whatever my point being
i don't want anyone to worry about me
thank you claudia and so if i say that
now you'll come back and watch this and
you'll be it'll bring you peace like it
really will if anything god forbid not
quote a million times ever happens to me
like i do believe this interview will
bring you peace someone remember this
day okay we'll remember the day it's the
bryson streisand extravaganza yeah i'm
not afraid
i'm not i'm not afraid
to
dance that's like the crazy thing i
wanted to say was that crazy like sort
like not that crazy but just bizarre no
bizarre but i do sometimes like lay in
bed thinking about like if anything were
to happen to me like my family would
obviously be so upset like i'm literally
the funniest person ever like you guys
would never laugh again i think in
general like death is is a
sadder for the people who have to live
without this person that's true that's
true but i think a lot of that sadness
comes from like you know the un like
what were they feeling in that moment
they were alone or something so i just
want you guys to know like in if that
moment ever comes like i will be okay
okay thank you for that strength you're
welcome like i'm doing it for you i do
what i do
for you now are you ready for our first
story because you clearly weren't ready
before no i'm glad i unburdened myself
yeah
rihanna's given birth she welcomes her
first baby with her boyfriend asap rocky
and she has given birth to a baby boy
page six can confirm the newborn was
born may 13th wow three months to the
day after prince harold in la according
to tmz
so cute oh in l.a in la i don't know why
i was under the assumption she was
giving birth because everyone just like
said that and then and make stuff up
because she took a trip there no and i
literally like perpetuated that rumor to
like millions of people millions so
so happy for her i don't know if we knew
that she was having a boy but that was
like a fast pregnancy sometimes
celebrity pregnancies feel like they go
on forever yeah i feel like these days a
lot of people are announcing around like
five months
and then it's another five months
because she announced like right when we
were doing remote podcasts when i was
like at the end of my pregnancy and it's
been three months yeah plus the fourth
give or take yeah no i i like that
because like you get one you get excited
for celebrities so when they tell you
super super early you're like this [ __ ]
has been pregnant for two years yeah
so happy for rihanna so happy i'm so
curious what she's going to name her bed
i know she's so creative like so it'll
probably be like william
not a problem if she's so creative it'll
probably be harry
imagine
do you just like i could see rihanna
like making everything mom related cool
now like for sure
breastfeeding
if that's what she chooses to do
uh
the doula i don't know all that [ __ ] you
have in your house yeah like the
perinatal right
things the diaper changing that's so
gonna be like the coolest hottest trend
of 2020 just spit up
burp cloths yes she's gonna make them
into like a handkerchief yeah yeah like
a
cool
you know she'll figure it out
avant-garde quilted burp cloth yeah
she's gonna make everything like cool
and i'm so happy for her um
i'm happy for i'm happy for the mama
community because we this is huge we
need all the icons we can get it's huge
for the ray dunn carrying mama community
ray dunn is the most incredible brand i
can't believe you didn't know about it i
can't believe i didn't know about it and
you got a pr package from them which was
huge i knew i got the jewelry i could
use some mugs yeah i love my number one
mom mug like i think it's does that say
number one mom or number one mama
number one mom i think
i think it's one of the best gifts i've
ever gotten and i'm not even lying a
toaster brought it to you at your meet
and greet oh and i transported it back
it really is the thought that counts no
that's so sweet and it's a reason why
literally every person who has kids uses
that mug no there is a reason behind the
success of right then it's not an
accident
nothing in life is an accident jackie no
ain't that the truth ain't that the
truth mazel tov biggest muzzle to
rihanna so happy for you
wishing you well wishing you well and
you know what these times
they are trying times but they're also
incredibly special i know and your bed
will never be this little again but also
it's the biggest it's ever been isn't
that crazy to think about yes it is also
um
i'm sorry i don't know why i cut you off
i have nothing to say
thank you for your your honor i'm just
being super honest and vulnerable today
okay this is such a safe space i should
ask you some questions that like you've
always invaded go for it from me
from you yeah i think i've literally
never told you anything
that's true i'll recognize there are no
secrets here i'll wrap my brain during
the next ad break
are you ready for our next story which
is actually really crazy and i'm very
curious to get your thoughts sure the
jersey shore stars are slamming the 2.0
show with a new cast they said it will
exploit the original so the original
stars of the jersey shore slammed mtv
for its upcoming reboot of the iconic
reality show with an entirely new cast
they wrote a collective statement which
was shared on social media on thursday
they said as a cast that took a chance
with a network in need we put our most
vulnerable moments on television for the
world to see
we gave our all all over the past 13
years became a family and continue to
open our lives to the world so please
understand that we are not in support of
a version of a version that will exploit
our original show our hard work and
authenticity to gain viewers i'm sorry
this is out of control
thank you holy [ __ ] cause i was feeling
really confused because i really love
the original show i love the cast
members me too and
i never thought that i could so
diametrically oppose such a firm stance
that they're taking this is insane
entitlement like yes you helped a
network in need but they were paying you
a million dollars an episode at one
point you all became huge celebrities to
this day you're making so much money
because of that show they gave you
another show a reboot family vacation
and you didn't invent the the jersey
show the jersey shore show
template
mtv did and they own that template and
they have every right to do another show
with another cast i don't think it'll be
as good because you really cannot
recreate the magic of the time it's
literally like that tick-tock sound i
know you don't know what i'm talking
about like it was the 70s you know
whatever oh hey boys um
so i think that this is just like an
enormous enormous mistake and
i don't think the show mistake for mtv i
don't think the show will be good
but i think these cast mates sound in
[ __ ] sane
jackie's giving the boys a little water
yeah bruno's tongue is hanging out of
his mouth in a way i've never seen
because they were just eating their
bones and they went on a walk and i
hadn't given him water yet i mean i
can't believe that they all read and
wrote this letter and not one person was
like do we sound crazy
i completely agree with you first of all
you know they took a chance they helped
out the network like still it's mtv
maybe they weren't in their heyday but
it's
mtv it's owned by viacom like they were
gonna be fine they were gonna be okay uh
i actually think a jersey shore 2.0 with
new cast members who are in the same you
know life stage that they were at back
in the day like sounds like a really
good idea you'll never be able to
recreate the magic it won't be the same
but it will make or break based on like
the cast members and i think it's a good
enough idea to give it a shot i think
they'll still continue to do family
vacation like this isn't affecting the
work that they're getting i think this
is really insane it's insane and they
all thought it was a good idea behavior
diva behavior every single one of them
signed it
yeah every single one with the hashtag
we are jersey shore
oh it's so out of touch i'm sorry like
this is insane and honestly i didn't
even know there was a 2.0 happening
and now it's like that's a good idea and
um
maybe i should watch no this is really
not a good look for anyone involved
and
they should delete this immediately like
seriously
yeah the damage is done but like they're
so wrong on this issue so so wrong and
it does sound like a good idea and the
network is allowed to do whatever the
[ __ ] it doesn't affect all the years of
success knowing that you even if the
show is successful it'll never reach the
level of like cultural
phenomena yeah that the original show if
anything it's like an ode and it'll keep
that old show people go back and watch
the original it'll keep it even more
relevant like these young
kids they they don't know about vinnie
like it's it's good rising tides rise
all ships or whatever it is so rising
ties rise all shines don't that's the
life lesson that you don't get it
twisted you couldn't pay to know no so
i think like they're being so
short-sighted and so dumb and
devalicious divalicious also think about
how many reboots there are out in the
world like of scripted shows of iconic
shows of reality shows etcetera and like
imagine if the cast of any of those
shows wrote something like this i mean i
could actually see like
it would actually be
no it would still be insane like
it's insane it's insane they they're
just looking delusional and out of touch
and it's actually a bad look and i never
thought i would say that about like the
way i used i
we used to idolize and really still do
idolize the cast like
it's one of the greatest shows of our
time
and i highly suggest spending a weekend
going back and re-watching some of the
early seasons they don't make better
television than that no and so if mtv
wants to try let them let them
crazy and this statement's not going to
do anything except like just make mtv
hate the original cast yeah and make
ordinary lay people like ourselves
question
confused yeah
are you ready for our next story if it's
a story that's brought to you by legacy
box the simplest and safest way to
digitize all of your aging video tapes
camcorder tapes film reels and pictures
so they are preserved forever legacy box
has been trusted by over a million
families to convert meaningful recorded
moments
so if your family's memories are trapped
on an old camcorder
on an old film reel you gotta check out
legacy box if you've got it they can
digitize it they can digitize over 19
different types of media from vhs tapes
to super eight film to preserve all your
treasured moments their exclusive
barcoded online tracking system keeps
you informed and it provides up to 12
email updates along the way it's super
easy and safe and the best part is that
you can buy it now and you don't have to
send it in immediately but like use our
code get it and then like once you have
all your vhs tapes ready to go then you
can send it in but just get it at least
with our code people are always asking
with you know father's day coming up
it's a really really nice gift and it's
a great way to spend like your parents
or grandparents birthday it's really
nice go to legacybox.com
toast to start future proofing your
memories today so you can gather the
family and begin the trip down memory
lane so that's legacybox.com toast to
get an incredible 40 off your first
order take advantage today of this
exclusive offer and send it in when
you're ready at legacybox.com
toast save 40
while supplies last
gorgeous thank you so much
today's episode theme i feel like it's
just like chaos
nostalgia heartwarming
legacy box is the perfect sponsor for
that totally uh also
speaking of nostalgia and books and
music
rolled dolls book matilda back rolled
off roald dahl the world juror with
urban berber
roll dolls matilda everyone knows
matilda made into the iconic movie once
a book by roald dahl
inspired a new song on harry styles
album the book
the book yes harry styles new song
matilda is about that matilda i'm sure
well sort of the grammy winner confirmed
speculation that roald dahl's iconic
children's book at least partly inspired
the acoustic track off his newly third
album harry's house
[Music]
it was about an experience that i had
with someone he explained on npr's
morning edition it was kind of like okay
we'll disguise it as speaking to matilda
now that she's all grown up who's been
kind of mistreated by her family and
stuff how would you speak to her the
1988 novel tells the story of an
extraordinarily gifted young girl who
teaches herself how to read and escape
from her ruthless parents and school
principal it was adapted into beloved
movie which we know and a broadway
musical wait that's so crazy first of
all i had like
no clue matilda was a book
um so i'm just learning so much today
and honestly what's crazy about this is
like harry probably had to like read
matilda to olivia wilde's kids like
that's why he was like reading it you
know or maybe why matilda was top of
mind and i guess so the story is
he's talking to a girl who has
been mistreated by her parents and
instead of using that girl's name he
used matilda because she's oh in a
similar situation that's cute i haven't
listened to any of harry's house yet i
didn't know this out yeah it came out
today i'm sure it's wonderful but i have
not spent time with it yet you know what
else came out today gavin duggar's new
album go check it out everyone jackie is
on gavin's payroll
gavin saw my mention i oh i told you i
didn't tell everyone and he clearly
didn't see the story because it expired
and so he wrote thanks for the mention
was i supposed to respond to that no
unless it was like with a picture of
your totes you know
gasp
just you wanted my honest opinion
today's honesty day
it's truth day here at the morning toast
christ what do you think about that
bryce loves gavin degra he said mom put
on that guy he said mom i have you to
thank for making me so
so hard to please actually that's
literally bryce he has made a thing um
wow matilda was a book like a children's
book or like a like ten pages or like no
no no you remember roll dolls books yeah
they were little chapter books for grade
schoolers yeah well you know charlie and
the chocolate factory wow that's so
crazy like all these major franchises
literally started with raw no look at
rolled like he's raking it in has role
been cancelled yet like i feel like oh
you know
yeah like did he go the shell
silverstein doctor no shel silverstein
what i know i think shel silverstein is
the one who's cancelled no dr seuss is
the one who's canceled okay cancelled
authors oh my god if she'll silver i'm
sorry you can't write the giving tree
and be cancelled like it's unfair pretty
sure it's shell silver no don't tell me
what he did even though and i was
watching 30 rock and literally
oh
rice holy [ __ ] they're farting
oh my god
putrid
and he wafted it with his with his tail
right in my face
[Laughter]
oh my god okay shel silverstein was
cancelled his book says banned banned
like some one of his books was based
olivia has a copy of the giving tree at
her house i just got one she's the best
most dr seuss books were pulled as well
and who was the other author that you
wanted okay so roll doll i don't know if
he's canceled that's what we were going
to see rolled up what did shel
silverstein do
in 30 rock they said it was a communist
but like i think that was a joke
uh
roald dahl inside his anti-semitism and
god looking at the leg let's see oh my
god okay canceled cancer can i say
something like controversial like okay
so roll doll was anti-semitic
who isn't you know like should his
entire life's work
be is that crazy like you're dead like
you can't be anti-semitic from the grave
should we not enjoy the books he is dead
so is that a bad take
no i mean it's like i didn't know when
we were talking about this yeah and like
you know what that's information i i
could have lived without knowing right
here charlie and the chocolate factory
matilda the bfg the witches james and
the giant peach like i'm sorry then
there's no books okay the estate of raul
doll must be making bank every single
one of those bfg was made into a movie
charlie the chocolate factory matilda
the witches was just made into a movie
remember the controversy
so i wonder how much the rule doll i
guess he doesn't care that he's canceled
because they
must be a multi billion dollars
they're rolling in the doll
totally
also his name was just fun to say
so yeah all of the childhood authors are
canceled do with that information what
you will i will still be reading the
giving tree to my child because i have
been reading i've been reading the cat
in the hat it's so [ __ ] fun to read
it's like the cat went that and the hat
went scat it's so funny
the cat in the hat is off the charts and
i don't know what the moral of the story
is because let me listen to your parents
i think that's the moral of the story no
no here's the premise the kids the
campers are home alone they're with
they're being babysit by their goldfish
and the cat comes in that's just bad
parenting yeah no the goldfish is like
the voice of reason this crazy-ass cat
comes in and he has all these things
cake rake bake shake and he makes this
huge mess and the whole time the
goldfish like cat you need to load up
i'm like not following okay so he comes
in with the cake the rake the bacon the
shake and he makes a huge mess and the
entire time the goldfish is like cat you
need to leave this house like the mother
is out you can't be about right and
cat doesn't give a [ __ ] but eventually
they see the mom's coming home
and it's clear the goldfish is like oh
my god mom's gonna freak et cetera et
cetera and the kids are quaking too and
the cat
magically cleans up everything before
the mom walks through the door the cat's
gone it's like nothing ever happened mom
comes in and the question the book ends
on a cliffhanger what we like do we tell
our mom what would you do it really
poses it poses a moral dilemma and no
you don't tell your [ __ ] mom
yeah obviously so what's the moral of
the story finding out if you're a good
person or not like a good person would
tell their mom and a bad person wouldn't
yeah but it's like what she doesn't know
won't hurt her and i really like why are
we gonna hurt our mom she's a single mom
like she's already working hard right
now she's gonna have a pit about leaving
her kids with a goldfish right when
there was literally everyone's fine at
the end of the day yeah so it really
gave you something to think about the
cat in the hat movie is one of the best
so good so good mike myers alec baldwin
like uh who does alec baldwin play
the boyfriend who tries to like send
them to military school okay just you
know that's not part of the book no of
course not it's a 10-page book jackie
that had to improvise yes bryce pardon
again i smelled it when he walked by me
he's out of control i think he needs
like a gas x these boys are going to
kill us oh my god it's gaseous as [ __ ]
in here
his are like literally putrid we need
you to catch the bone he's never made a
fart that smells like it's actually
making me gag
we need gas masks
no we need n95s
he's not okay oh my god bryce you're so
cute it's a like this there's a lot
going on for him so i'm happy for harry
styles at the end of the day at the end
of the day agreed at the end of the day
great one direction song is that the
lyrics
oh
don't forget where you belong thank you
if you ever feel alone
do they that would say
you were ever on your own and the proof
they never say at the end of the day but
they have a song called at the end of
the day yeah you know what
what was i watching yesterday
kardashians
the phrase at the end of the day is the
most overused phrase on reality tv
you'll start to hear it now okay like on
love island at the end of the day
okay we get it like just say what you
were gonna say totally like it could be
the middle of the day right and it would
still be true
[Laughter]
are you ready for our next story a
little movie news yes bryce and nice
you're being too distracted by bryce
like get to the story sorry oh my god oh
my god margot robbie will start on an
ocean's eleven prequel here's everything
we know oh that's that's good
margo robbie has been tapped to join a
new ocean's eleven film warner brothers
confirms to e news according to the
hollywood reporter margaret will star in
and produce the movie which will be led
by bombshell director jay roach he
directed bombshell he's not a bomb
shelter oh some might say he is a
bombshell director as well the new
oceans film which will begin production
next spring why are we talking about
this will also be produced by margo's
husband tom ackerley thank you um it is
known to be an original ocean's 11 that
is set in europe in the 1960s because
the initial ocean's eleven was released
in 1960 and starred frank sinatra dean
martin and sammy davis junior love
i think this is going to be fantastic
it's so great to have an actress like
margot robbie because like if she's in
it it's a good project yeah because
she's like a director producer she's a
production company so i'm sure her
production company is putting it
together so you know that you're going
to the theater to see a margot robbie
piece of art like it's good yes she has
yet to flop she's yet to flop which is a
lot of pressure
but it's nice for us because you know
there's a really low chance of you not
liking the film yeah
what else has she been in has she really
nice wolf of wall street oh so good that
was like her breakthrough role was it
yeah and then i tanya
suicide squad yes that's where she made
her money you know yeah bombshell oh she
was in bombshell so they must have liked
working together mary queen of scots i
saw that one
did i yeah i did
with joe owen
yeah and uh
svarshay
oh she was in focus with will smith was
that good i didn't see it or hear
anything about it maybe it flopped well
she's been in so many movies it just
also feels like she hasn't been around
for that long i know i know i agree
interesting
barbie you know today was allegedly the
day that legally blonde three was
supposed to come out like when we spoke
about it years ago and have they even
started filming i don't even think the
script has been written i'm so done
talking about these projects but one
thing about margot robbie is she's going
to get it done yeah she's going to get
it done i will definitely be seeing this
same are you ready for our fifth and
final story i am it's some downtown news
because the downton characters are in
the press because the movie is
premiering like over the course of the
next few weeks i don't know it literally
comes out
tomorrow tomorrow may 21st right
we should see it this weekend oh my god
i'm so excited downton
movie
because it like came out earlier in the
uk in australia in the us may 20th okay
oh my gosh we should see today we should
take the stress brothers no they're
insane look at them they're such good
boys now look at bryson yeah it only
took them two hours of running around
and a couple deadly farts yeah
anyways the characters are doing on a
press tour and downton abbey star kevin
doyle who plays mosley is standing up
for his quote sad character he said he
has a pair
of balls or yes but of course he like
it's too so british
for his own good kevin doyle is quite
protective of his downton abbey
character valet footman balot sorry
joseph mosley didn't know his first name
was joseph when the post suggested that
mosley could could be a tad tepid and
perhaps grow up grow a pair
doyle took issue he said i disagree with
that actually i know some sort some
people sort of think that way about him
but i think he's got a really beautiful
spirit about him the thing about him is
that he has been thwarted a lot in his
life he's had a lot of sadness in his
life and what's been lovely in the past
few years especially is seeing him move
away from that sadness and obviously
characters like baxter his love interest
helped him with that so i don't agree i
think he has a pair he's not been able
to let them hang by the way it's true he
was way sadder in the beginning like
once he started like standing up for
himself and then he got his partner
baxter and he got his teaching job oh
yeah like he just couldn't find his
place in this world right i think he's
totally like on a great trajectory i
think so too and i i love his demeanor
me too it took me a while because at
first i was like there's mosley couldn't
get arrested like literally needed a job
is such a trained ballot and like
literally nobody would hire him because
like
he just couldn't figure it out yeah um
but no he's totally i think a
respectable king now yeah i've loved his
journey he's really a sleeper character
i'm so excited for the downton movie
so excited let's make plans i know you
didn't like the first one that much
i didn't but i miss everyone and i just
want to see them again even though i
didn't like it i didn't like it as much
as i liked downton the show which was
like a 20 out of 10. so the movie for me
was like still probably a 10 out of 10
but just movie for me was just like one
more episode you know
yeah it was just like a little stupid
even it was playing on nbc the other day
so i was watching it and i was like
remembering how stupid it is it's like
you know the servants being mad that
they can't cook and like they're gonna
you know break the boiler or servant's
hygiene some yeah it was crazy but if
you watch the show and then just
immediately watch the movie
it's just like one more episode but if
you watch the show in real time waited
years for the movie it's like we just
waited all this time for another i was
saving the movie that was my problem i
should have watched it right after i was
saving it for a rainy day and then it
just didn't live up to you know what i
had hyped it up to be yeah
um so those are the past five you
definitely do not need to know them if
we're gonna be honest with you you
didn't need to know that rihanna gave
birth but you didn't need to know that
shell silver scene was cancelled because
no one really needed to know that no
nobody did or rolled
or dr seuss the trifecta yeah i knew
about dr seuss because he's like the
most famous one he was the face of the
campaign you know oh that's so
interesting because when i was reading
dr seuss yesterday to harold i was like
is he canceled i was like oh no that's
shel silverstein
oh i only know dr seuss got it
but again i can't stress enough like i
will be buying that book for my child
yeah no you there's no greater lesson
than the giving tree it's so true and
the lesson is no good deed goes on
punishment people give and use people
are disgusting
humanity is evil that is the takeaway
from the book yeah
they you give and you give and you give
and you take what you get
and you turn it into something honestly
you're never going to find me thank you
i forgot the words no
no
no
all right let's dive into the tv recap
of kardashians on hulu which is brought
to you by zocdoc
no one knows what you're looking for in
a doctor better than you and no one's
better at giving you the tools to find
the perfect doctor than zocdoc the
people who created zocdoc found the
major pain points in healthcare all the
things that weren't working and said
enough they made a great doctor surprise
they made booking a great doctor
surprisingly pain-free
doc is a free app that shows you doctors
who are patient reviewed take your
insurance and are available when you
need them you can read up on local
doctors get verified patient reviews and
see what other real human beings had to
say about their visit so when you walk
into that doctor's office you're set up
to see someone in your network who
totally gets you go to zocdoc.com choose
a time slot and whether you want to see
the doctor in person or do a video visit
and just like that you're booked find
the doctor that is right for you and you
book an appointment on your schedule
that works for you every month millions
of people are using zocdoc we are two of
them it is our go-to whenever we need to
find a book a doctor and if you travel a
lot for work it's nice to have the
resource of just being able to do like a
facetime video chat with a doctor if you
don't have like a local doctor for when
you're traveling
in the chaotic world worlds of
healthcare let sockdoc be your trusted
guide go to zocdoc.com toast and
download the zocdoc app for free then
start your search for a top rated doctor
today many are available within 24 hours
that's z-o-c-d-o-c
dot com
toast z-o-c-d-o-c
zocdoc dot com slash toast great thank
you look at the streis brothers they are
out they're passed out they're passed
down so kardashian's on hula was really
good i am obsessed i could watch an
entire show about kim's
law social justice yeah
she did an entire show about it i think
that that scene of her with the white
board and that guy scott was the
craziest thing and you know what it's
like
so many people like
first of all it was so cool to see which
celebrities like kim had access to just
immediately james corden and demi lovato
she's like i'll take down the motto katy
perry i loved that
but just to see someone who like
i don't know there was like something so
amazing about it like
it was like such a crisis kim was on the
horn
the way like they would mention a
celebrity's name and they would post the
tweet that the celebrity post like it
was just so cool to see how all that
goes down yeah and kim was like we need
to make a cert and i remember
when it happened i was like oh man
everyone is like now talking about this
in the last hour because it was like so
short they didn't have a lot of time
yeah so it was it was amazing that scene
with the white board and the expo
markers and the phones like it was in
the checks and at first i didn't know
what the checks meant but then that
meant that they posted yeah i thought it
was interesting that demi lovato like
her screenshot didn't go up you know
even though do you think that she posted
i'm sure she did but i just thought that
was interesting you know who kim had
gwen with paltrow's number like yeah
that's just what you like what you get
when you're literally the most powerful
woman in hollywood yeah that scene was
incredible it was incredible everything
so much about the episode it really
focused on her
legal work and her
bar it was so good the scene where she
gets her test results in the parking lot
at red lobster and north had just won
her basketball game like if you didn't
cry you're not alive i don't know you it
was no and also when she showed footage
of someone who she had tried to save
from death row like her final phone call
with him because they weren't able to
grant clemency like that was
like
that was so sad and like he was
comforting her and she was
it was just it was really tough to watch
but like it's so it's so interesting to
me and like you would think like
they're so like superficial like glam
glam glam no this is like so good this
type of content yeah no but it's we got
we get it all yeah and i feel like
especially this show they've been doing
that for a while and kim's been showing
like her
criminal justice reform work for a while
but like you know in the same episode
you get kanye taking his kids to school
in a fire truck like you get all of
these different things both fluffy and
very very real and serious which is
great also when kim was saying that um
you know how being a lawyer like ages
you so much and she was like thank god
for botox was that just me or is it like
the first time that she's admitted to
having botox because remember years ago
she got it on the show and then had like
a rash and she's like i can never get it
right and i don't know if she's ever
really admitted
i mean to it not dumb she's 40 and she
looks [ __ ] tired i know but it's like
she looks so good that i'm like maybe
she doesn't get botox she's getting
something better maybe like maybe but
maybe she was using a layperson's term
like botox because we wouldn't know
right no she's definitely getting
something better than the rest of us
because she looks serious good the ins
and outs of like their days especially
when chloe and tristan were using their
gym and then like kanye like kim just
like sends her kids off to school in a
robe something i didn't know but like i
needed to know yeah when
kim and kanye were just like being
co-parents and so cute and kanye was
talking to the camera and she was like
it's gonna be 45 minutes love
love love love when chloe and tristan
are just talking about anything don't
love don't love
and it's like that's where i feel like
the show really missed out on having a
faster turnaround because like we really
shouldn't be watching this like we
should have known but we love chloe we
love chloe and i don't want her to see i
don't want her scenes cut no no no no no
i agree i agree but like if they had
turned around the show a little bit
faster we would literally be have
watching have watched this like three
months ago and now we would be watching
like them fall apart you know mm-hmm so
i'm looking forward to that
yeah um i think the kendall scott thing
is like so asinine and like i know it
sounds crazy but like i am team scott
i'm team scott like no one is being
clear with him so he's like kind of
being left out in the dust and they're
gas lighting him i had a party i didn't
have a party it was a dinner no it was a
party like they're gaslighting him and
all he wants to know is like why wasn't
i invited yeah because they say like
i love you
it's all good so why don't you invite me
right also courtney and travis are
getting married this weekend in italy
italy yes at a castle at a castle at the
uh dolce gabbana castle
they're like very dolce gabon yeah
i love it kim's on her way her plane was
tracked oh was it okay i saw in liz
heights story and i'm sure she's gonna
have all the content this weekend from
this weekend i think it'll be so nice
like they're chooky like they're getting
married in italy like it's so cute yeah
i think it'll be um a glorious affair
it's so crazy courtney's never been
married yeah and apparently
they're getting married there it's like
small close friends and family and then
they're going to do a big party in la so
it's like a fourth wedding by the way
god yeah fourth but i guess you know
they're so obsessed with each other like
watching them on the show with their
heads i actually they're weirdly like so
normal and
the blended family to themselves even
when no not even the family stuff it was
last week when they were getting the ivf
retrieval and they were like in the
doctor's office and there was something
just so like quaint about them even
though they pulled up in a tour bus yes
but they just and like they showed up in
matching onesies like they're just
yet
really no it's so weird it's like they
are like larger than life the tour bus
and his tattoos and like she's a
kardashian but there's something very
simple and you know they are a little
cringy but they are super in love and i
thought that dinner scene just like a
regular you know week night it looked
delicious vegan no it didn't no it
looked good
it looked them being like so regular
and all the kids and cory was like i
really really love his kids it was like
it was literally blended the movie like
yeah it was beautiful it was beautiful
and when chloe was talking about how
like good they are at like bringing
people into their family blending
families because they learned it like
from robert and
chris it was just so sweet you know
it's so true like the amount of people
who've come in and out of their family
like it's so not normal but also the way
that like they are
you know kim courtney chloe are with
kendall and kylie even though they're
technically half-sisters right we don't
even think of them but like they
literally have different last names no
that's so true but like they're fully
blood-related like no that's a good call
um so it wasn't like a crazy episode but
i really loved kim's story line like i
wanted more kim more kim more candy i
always want more kim me too where the
[ __ ] is kylie
pregnant also we're in like astro world
oh right
and so i think that like we even if
she's you know getting her nails done
we're not going to see it because then
it's like kylie got her nails done after
actually right right no that's that's
good so they need to like wait for some
time i'm sure she may actually i don't
know if she's in the preview for next
week and her and chris look like they're
doing some moronic e pranks i think that
because like she was slacking last few
episodes because she couldn't be in them
like now she's like okay let's do stuff
yeah like go to get groceries because
like we're all making the same amount i
need to pull my weight put me in coach
yeah yeah
um
so yeah i'm loving the hulu show like
loving i mean it's just gorgeous
television it's
but i don't feel any urgency to watch it
me neither but i did get a really
interesting piece of information
yesterday
do you remember in the final season of
the e-show they during kobit they rented
that like sick malibu house
belongs to diana jenkins
the new real housewife of beverly hills
i forget where i saw that i apologize
who told me that thank you for that
thank you very much that's something i
needed to know
so they're friends with diana jenkins
well diana said she was with kim in
paris when she was robbed yes
where does she fit into the mix i have
no clue
but this is just one step closer to
getting chris jenner on the road house
of beverly hills
that house and the staircase and the
staircase elevator belongs to diana
jenkins there was a staircase remember
the staircase to the beach that really
yes yes yes like the caravan and then it
was like a
you know a little cart
yeah yeah i forgot about that gorgeous
home gorgeous um so that's my little
factoid of the day and that's our show
if you got nothing else out of the show
like you need that you needed to know so
i'm glad you made it till the end an
hour later you finally learned something
thank you so much for listening to the
morning monday morning show where we
deliver the fast side stories today you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please subscribe give this video
a thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast and we're podcasting foundation
spotify itunes stitcher public video
everybody catch box on the place to
babysit but guess find us somebody show
cbf story about a beautiful setting and
smart we are have an amazing weekend you
guys will see you next week on monday
bye bye thank you bye streis brothers
for joining us you did so good my angel